TWO COP TENDERS THIS EVENING
HAVE MARRIED EACH OTHER.
NOT TONIGHT YEARS AGO.
RACHEL CAMPOS-DUFFY
REGULARLY HERE ON FOX.
HER HUSBAND IS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM WISCONSIN.
CONGRESSMAN SEAN DUFFY AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
STRENGTHEN RATHER THAN
DIVIDE THEIR UNION.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU, TOO.
>> Tucker: PLOWING NEW
GROUND HERE.
>> EXCITED TO BE PART OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: WE'RE EXCITED
TOO.
YOU KNOW THE RULES FOR THE
SAKE PEOPLE WATCHING AT
HOME.
FIRST CONTESTANT TO BUZZ
GETS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL FINISH
ASKING IT IN ORDER TO
ANSWER.
ACKNOWLEDGE BY SAYING YOUR
NAME.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH
ONE POINT.
GET IT WRONG WE DETRACT A
POINT THE COOL MATH OF FINAL
EXAM BEST OF FIVE WINS.
READY?
>> READY.
>> ANY CHANCE TO WIN IT.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY
WINNING DOESN'T ACTUALLY GET
YOU A VICTORY THAT'S ANOTHER
SHOW ENTIRELY.
ACCORDING TO THE RULES NAMED
OUT BY THE NATIONAL GAME
SHOW COMMISSION ALL OF
TODAY'S QUESTIONS MUST BE
EITHER ABOUT FOOD OR
ANIMALS.
WE WENT WITH FOOD.
FIRST QUESTION IS THIS.
MULTIPLE CHOICE.
PLEASE LISTEN CAREFULLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE
DOESN'T CARE WHAT LAWMAKERS
CALL THE BORDER AND OFFERED
A FOOD RELATED SUGGESTION
WHICH NAME DID HE SUGGEST?
WAS IT A QUARTER POUNDER
WITH CHEESE?
B, PANCAKES, C, PEACHES?
I THINK IT GOES BY
DEFINITION TO YOUR HUSBAND.
I'M SORRY.
THE JUDGES HAVE WEIGHED IN
ON THIS.
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH C.
PEACHES.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE GOING TO
GO IN WITH C.
PEACHES?
>> WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL
IT IS OKAY WITH ME.
THEY CAN NAME IT WHATEVER
THEY CAN NAME IT PEACHES.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY NAME
IT.
WE NEED MONEY.
PEACHES.
>> PEACHES.
>> Tucker: YOU BOTH KNEW
THAT.
>> I DID.
I THOUGHT THE QUESTION WAS
OVER.
>> Tucker: YOU KNEW IT TOO
WELL.
>> I DID.
>> ALL MULTIPLE CHOICE HAVE
TO BE.
>> Tucker: WAIT UNTIL WE
FINISH ASKING THE QUESTION.
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: WE CAN DO IT THIS
TIME.
COSTCO THE STORE SAYS IT HAS
SOLD OUT OF A 27 TUB OF FOOD
THAT HAS A SHELF LIFE OF 20
YEARS.
WHAT TYPE OF FOOD WAS IT?
>> THAT WAS NOT RIGHT I HIT
IT FIRST.
>> IT WAS MACARONI AND
CHEESE.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU HAVE
TO HOLD IT COUNSEL.
>> I HIT IT FIRST FOR SURE.
>> Tucker: IT WAS MACARONI
AND CHEESE.
>> EVERYBODY LOVES MACARONI
BUT NOW YOU CAN GET
27 POUNDS.
>> THAT'S MY VOICE THAT'S
HOW I KNEW IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY NEED TO
INVEST IN THAT.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: I'M GETTING ONE
MYSELF.
>> I'M A PREPPER.
>> Tucker: YOUR OFFICIAL
POSITION ON PREPARING IS
THAT'S CRAZY.
QUESTION THREE.
ANOTHER MULTIPLE CHOICE,
OKAY.
A WORLD RECORD WAS SET THIS
WEEK FOR THE MOST LIKED
INSTAGRAM PHOTO EVER.
THE PICTURE DOESN'T FEATURE
A FAMOUS PERSON OR EXOTIC
PLACES NEARLY 50 MILLION
LIKES.
IT'S A PLAIN BORING
PHOTOGRAPH OF, WHAT?
A, A BANANA, B, A LEMON, C,
AN EGG.
CONGRESSMAN?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH C,
AN EGG.
KYLIE JENNER TWEET THE EGG
OUT?
>> Tucker: I HAVE NO IDEA.
I'M NOT A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
IS IT C, AN EGG?
>> WORD RECORD EGG AN
ACCOUNT WITH THAT VERY NAME
POSTED THIS SINGLE PHOTO A
PICTURE OF AN EGG.
EGG CURRENTLY HAS 26 MILLION
LIKES.
HOW DOES THAT --
>> Tucker: EITHER YOU LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY YOUR WHOLE
LIFE AND DON'T UNDERSTAND
IT.
>> LOOKS LIKE EGG COMMISSION
THAT PROMOTES EGGS.
THEY NEED A BONUS.
>> Tucker: PALTRY
>> Tucker: PULTRY
>> Tucker: PULLRY
>> Tucker: PULL POULTRY
LOVE.
QUESTION FOUR.
ONE LAST MULTIPLE CHOICE.
>> I'M WINNING THOUGH,
RIGHT?
IT'S 2 TO 1.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT FOR ME
TO KEEP SCORE OUR VIEWERS
ARE WATCHING.
CHAOS HIT FLAGSTAFF MONDAY
WHEN A TANKER TRUCK FLIPPED
OVER SPILLING WHICH KIND OF
LIQUID ALL OVER THE HIGHWAY
A CHOCOLATE, B COFFEE, C
BEER.
RACHEL?
>> Rachel: BEER, C.
>> WAS IT C?
BEER?
>> 3500 GALLONS THAT'S HOW
MUCH LIQUID CHOCOLATE
SPILLED IN ARIZONA
INTERSTATE.
A CHOCOLATE RIVER THEY
DESCRIBED IT FORMING AFTER A
TANKER CARRIED.
>> I KNEW I WAS LOSING.
I FIGURED BEER.
>> Tucker: YOU DOUBLED DOWN.
I ADMIRE THAT.
>> SHE IS FROM WISCONSIN SO
OF COURSE IT'S BEER.
>> Tucker: ALL RIGHT.
FULL-TIME QUESTION.
THE CLEMSON TIGERS INVITED
TO THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A
CANDLE LIT FEAST TO
CELEBRATE THE RECENT VICTORY
OVER ALABAMA.
WHAT TYPE OF FOOD DID THE
PRESIDENT SERVE THE TEAM?
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY?
>> I WAS THERE THIS MORNING.
MCDONALD'S.
FOOD CAME I WAS THERE THIS
MORNING.
>> Tucker: WAS IT
MCDONALD'S?
>> WE HAVE PIZZAS, WE HAVE
300 HAMBURGERS, MANY, MANY
FRENCH FRIES.
ALL OF OUR FAVORITE FOODS.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT'S HERE
WHEN WE LEAVE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE MUCH.
>> CARLOS OWNED THE STORE.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO SAY IT
WASN'T EXCLUSIVELY WE ARE
HEARING MCDONALD'S BUT
MCDONALD'S WAS REPRESENTED
AND YOU ARE RIGHT.
YOU STILL WIN BECAUSE
MCDONALD'S, WENDY'S AND WE
WILL CALL.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY FAST
FOOD.
>> Tucker: BURGER KING IT
WAS ECUMENICAL.
>> CARLOS OWNS MCDONALD'S
THEY GAVE THE FOOD TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Tucker: IMPRESSIVE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A
SHUTDOWN.
I HAVE BEEN HOME WITH THE
KIDS.
OF COURSE HE KNOWS.
>> Tucker: REALLY A VICTORY
FOR YOUR FAMILY.
PRO-FAMILY ON THIS SHOW.
I'M GOING A WARD OUR ERIC
WEMPLE MENNIVE MUG TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> I WENT AND WATCHED THE
EPISODE THAT YOU HAD WITH
HIM ON IT WAS GREAT.
>> Tucker: WHEN I'M FEELING
SAD SOMETIMES I PULL IT UP.
IT LIFTS ME.
>> OR IF YOU ARE ON A
SHUTDOWN.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY, RIGHT.
IT'S AMAZING.
ALL RIGHT, THAT'S IT FOR